how are people going to go
it's absolutely right these are shocking
levels of increases
i represent wolverhampton southeast
we've got a lot of low-income families
in a constituency like that i've been on
the doorstep in recent weeks and people
are really worried about this they don't
know how they're going to pay and even
before
these risers have been announced people
have been so fearful they've been
turning their heating off even in very
cold weather
fearful about what's coming
and this is
just one part of a triple whammy that's
coming at households right now you've
got the energy price uh rises which
we're talking about today you've also
got tax rises coming in in april and
you've got declining real wages and
these three things are coming together
to squeeze household incomes in a way
that we haven't seen for many many years
doing what he can though isn't he well
the chancellor's come to this very very
late we've uh we've been calling
for action on energy prices for months
now we've been talking about cutting the
vat from energy prices and we produced a
fully costed package uh right at the
beginning of the year which would have
offered households 200 pounds
off the bill for everyone with another
400 pounds off for the poorest families
and we did that in a fully costed way
what's interesting about the speculation
about what the chancellor might announce
today is that he's not asking
the oil and gas companies who are making
the most out of all this to pay a single
penny towards this instead he's doing it
on a buy now pay later yeah although
it's the prime minister who said that
that's not going to happen but you know
the prime minister tells us lots of
things that are not going to happen and
then potentially they do is that the way
forward
well we just win full time when we
produced our package
we did it in a fully costed way because
if i'd come in here kay and said we're
going to do this and that on energy
bills the first question you'd have
asked me is how are you going to pay for
it
so we did that in a fully costed way by
contrast certainly as far as the
speculation goes
today the chancellor is going to
announce what is in effect a buy now pay
later scheme where he borrows the money
for this from taxpayers and asks them to
repay in future years
i've got no money and he doesn't ask the
oil and gas companies to pay a penny let
me give you an example shell have just
announced their recent profits they made
a profit of 20 billion dollars last year
the chief executive described it as a
momentous year
they're planning share buybacks and
increase dividends but they're not being
asked to pay a penny towards the package
so all roads are leading back to a
windfall tax is that what you're saying
well i think the package should be fully
costed and let me place this in a wider
context this week we've already learned
that 4.3 billion has been written off by
the government on covet fraud we've
learnt that almost nine billion has been
written off on ppe costs and now we have
a package that might cost five or six
billion where he doesn't ask for any
extra contribution towards it and you do
have to ask yourself why have the
conservatives become so complacent about
public money
well they would say that we're in the
middle of a pandemic because i put these
those points to um the uh to michael
gove yesterday all sorts of reasons he
gave to me for that but nevertheless let
me just ask you once more are we looking
is labor suggesting a windfall tax would
be the right way forward yes we've been
saying that for some weeks okay okay as
far as the prime minister is concerned
it's called a cream tea coo it's never
going to catch on it's not catchy at all
is it um
how much longer has he got
look i can't you know i can't guess this
boris johnson has been a survivor he's
always got out of scrapes usually by
making somebody else clean up the mess
this is down to him on the one hand and
to conservative mps on the other
i think the problem reflecting in the
last few months is
uh just what he's done to degrade the
office to degrade trust and it's quite
cynical in the end because he hopes to
survive
on the basis that everybody will think
all politicians are rogues and to drag
everyone down to his level and i think
the country
and our governance deserves better than
that he got a slap on the wrists before
prime minister's questions yet yesterday
from uh from the speaker but then he
doubled down again talking about jimmy
chavel is your leader just going to
leave that
well he raised it yesterday and
you know i think that comment from boris
johnson says more about him than anybody
else the fact that our prime minister
would reach into the
darkest corners of
internet rubbish and repeat it not once
but twice now in the house of commons
says quite a lot about his approach to
life and as i say it's revealing of him
and his character but it doesn't say
anything about kirsten because it's not
true
um talk to me about ukraine um we had
four russian jets buzzing our borders
yesterday the raf went up and saw them
off they didn't come into british
airspace
but um he's just testing the borders
isn't he just testing where the
boundaries are that's exactly what he's
doing and well done to the raf who are
constantly in the skies
keeping us safe
we've got to show
maximum solidarity with nato my party
founded nato
and that alliance of western countries
has helped keep us safe since the end of
the second world war and we've got to
say to president putin that it's up to
the people of ukraine to decide their
own future and their own path in the
future it's not up to him to act in an
old imperialist way through this concept
of spheres of influence where he gets to
decide what kind of government exists in
neighbouring countries to his own are we
doing enough as a country to help well i
still think that whatever's happening
domestically we have respect through
having a strong military and we've got
to show not in a reckless way but we've
got to show that that military is there
that we stand in solidarity with our
allies nato is a solidarity alliance
that's what it is and we've got to make
that very clear especially to those
countries in eastern europe who are
members who'll be very fearful now when
they see that kind of russian aggression
i don't know if you've seen
our alex crawford's report on
afghanistan it was running
last night we can't actually show our
viewers until after nine o'clock because
it is so so distressing my goodness me
any parent watching and it is you know
you must watch it but it is absolutely
terrible to watch lots of children
particularly babies who are struggling
in afghanistan 22.8 million people
facing severe hunger 8.7 million are on
the brink of starvation
how can we have allowed this
humanitarian catastrophe to unfold
i haven't seen the report that you're
talking about but
i believe you know i've seen others
which which and you're absolutely right
in terms of how you
how you sum it up uh there are millions
of people on the edge of starvation
there are parents having to sell their
children
in order to try to buy food food for a
few hundred dollars the world must set
up
and and that too the world must set up
it must do more and
you know just because the taliban are
running that country we can't let the
people there starve so countries that
have the means to help
and we are in a position where we do
have some means to help together with
other similar countries i've got to make
sure the aid gets to the people there
the others running the country sure when
i when i put that to therese coffee last
week working pension secretary she said
we're doing our bit
look um
we've got to we can't just turn our
backs on this because
our military's pulled out because of the
change that happened in august uh
when you see millions of people in the
edge of starvation you've got to act in
concert with other countries who can
help to do so it would be the most
appalling
humanitarian catastrophe to let this get
any worse
but what level of responsibility should
we accept given that it was such a
chaotic withdrawal
well i don't see it so much as a sort of
responsibility in that way but it's a
responsibility in a human way when you
look at people who are starving whether
it's an economy that's just not
functioning you can hardly speak about a
functioning economy uh there at all and
whoever's fault all this is it's not the
fault of people in afghanistan who are
starving and that's why i ask the united
states france germany other countries
who have means have got to do more to
get help to people though okay it's good
to talk to you thanks for coming in much
appreciated